-We are back with
Daniel Craig, everyone.
One question on a lot of
people's minds is,
"Who is the next Bond?"
And I know that you're
not involved or maybe you are,
but what advice would you give
to the next Bond?
-Don't [bleep] it up.
I mean...
-[ Laughs ] Oh, my God.
Oh, my gosh. That is genius.
-It's a beautiful, beautiful,
amazing thing.
It's like, don't [bleep] it up.
Leave it better
than when you found it.
-That's great.
-Is that right? Can I say that?
Probably not. Okay.
-You are allowed to do
whatever you want.
You're James Bond. Come on.
You cannot have a Bond movie
without a great song.
And you have
a great one in this.
Billie Eilish and Finneas wrote
and recorded "No Time to Die."
They're going to perform it,
actually, tonight on our show.
-I'm so excited to see that.
-How do you hear the songs when
they send it to you?
Do they go,
"Okay, what do you think?
-Well, what normally
happens is that
there's a sort of
rough cut of the song
that the musician will record.
And it happened with Adele
and it happened
with Billie, as well.
And it's sort of secretly sent
on a music file to a phone,
and we all kind of keep it --
You know, we try and keep it
as secret as we possibly can,
because it's important
to keep it under wraps.
But I kind of want to -- I need
to listen to it.
And earphones
are never quite good enough,
and my office at Pinewood
is next to other offices,
so I can't crank it up.
So, there's usually
a fancy car parked outside
somewhere at Pinewood,
whether it's an Aston Martin
or it's a Range Rover
or something,
and they tend to have
pretty good stereos in them.
So I'll get in the car
and drive it somewhere
and then just crank it up
and listen to it
like 10 or 15 times.
'Cause then you get it --
Because you need to kind of
vibrate with the song.
And, you know, this song is --
Especially with Billie's song,
it was just like,
"Well, we've got this."
-If you had to pick your
three favorite
Bond songs of all time --
-Oh, no!
-No, but not including
"No Time to Die."
-Okay, okay, okay, okay.
-Not including "No Time to Die."
-Okay, you go first.
-Me go first?
-Yes.
-I think you got "Goldfinger,"
Shirley Bassey.
♪ Goldfinger ♪
♪ He's the man ♪
I love that one. I love --
-It's great.
Those horns are so violent.
I listened to that
again recently.
It's really, like, a scream.
-I like "Thunderball,"
Tom Jones.
-Yeah. You know
the story of that one,
don't you, with Tom Jones?
-No.
-Supposedly, on the last take,
which was the one they used,
he held the note for so long,
he passed out in the booth.
You ever hear that?
-No.
-I don't know if it's true,
but I love it.
I like to think it's true.
-For that last...
♪ Thunderba-a-a-a-a-ll ♪
Oh, my gosh.
That's the only way to do it.
-They were like, "Wow, Tom!
That's great, Tom."
Where has he gone?"
-Yeah, I mean, honestly,
there's so many good ones.
I would say "Live and Let Die."
-Yeah, no, that's great.
I mean, truly, I'll leave
this one out the way,
but I think this is brilliant,
Billie's,
and it's definitely up there.
I mean, in fact,
it's in the top three.
But if I have to name,
I mean, Adele is --
When I first heard that,
that was like, "Oh, my God."
I've got a sort of soft spot for
"GoldenEye" because of Tina.
-Oh, yeah.
-And "Nobody Does It Better,"
because it's so kind of
not a Bond theme,
but it's Carly Simon,
and I had a
massive, massive, massive crush
on Carly Simon when I was a kid.
-We have something
very special tonight.
You brought an exclusive clip
from "No Time to Die"
that we are premiering tonight.
Before we show it, is there
any setup you want to give or --
-I think this is
the one which comes towards
the beginning of the movie,
where, you know,
when I read the script
and it says,
"Run down bridge
and be chased by the bad guys,
jump off bridge,"
it's like, "Oh, here we go."
-Here we go.
Here's Daniel Craig in
"No Time to Die."
Take a look.
♪♪
[ Bullets ricocheting,
tires screech ]
-Yes! Come on! Standing ovation!
Oh, my gosh!
Yes! Yes!
That's what we want.
I love it.
Daniel Craig, you are awesome.
"No Time to Die"
hits theaters in the spring.